[WHOOSH]
PAUL RASHIDI: Hi.
My name is Paul Rashidi and I'm
with the Google Cloud Platform
team.
Today we're going to discuss
how to build the Hello Endpoints
Android application
from scratch.
We'll be helped by
GitHub gist that
will contain most of the
code we would normally
write and commented in
as we talk about it.
So let's get started.
The first step we'll take is
setting up a Cloud Endpoints
back end.
This is actually pretty easy.
We cloned a Cloud Endpoints
back end sample from GitHub
like this, but do
note there is also
a Python version
available as well.
In order to get the Java back
end running on a local machine,
we'll perform two steps.
We'll uncomment a line in
this Maven pom XML file
to specify that we want
to run on all IP addresses
on the local machine.
This will allow our
Android application
to access the back
end application,
since will be using an emulator,
which can't access local host.
The other change
we'll need to make
is editing the App
Engine Web XML file
to update the
app's [? vod ID ?].
Since we won't be deploying
remotely to App Engine,
this idea is only
affecting the Java package
name of our generated classes.
You should use the developer
console to register an ID
and use that value here.
Easy enough.
We'll save and exit.
So, just to quickly recap-- we
only made these two changes.
Now, to run this
back end locally,
we will invoke it via Maven.
In this command, install is
building our application.
And the dev server
command is running it
on our local dev server.
You should know,
the first time you
run this command on a machine,
it will take a little bit
longer than normal because Maven
will download the App Engine
plugin.
Now that our server
is running, let's
take a look at it
in our API Explorer.
This is very handy if you're
not familiar with an API
but still want to
play around with it.
We'll use this URL.
We'll select our API.
And we'll run the
list command here.
We see that our service is
returning two messages-- hello
world and goodbye world.
Now that we have a
working test server,
let's get to the Android app.
We'll switch to Android
Studio to create our project.
The first thing
we're going to do
is create a new Android
application via the New Project
Wizard.
We'll adjust some project
names here and then select
a minimum API level of eight.
The client libraries
that we will create
will need this minimum level.
We'll take the rest
of the defaults
and create this project.
I'll speed the video
up a little so you
don't have to wait
for the initial build.
And there we have it.
This is a typical
default Android project
with a single main activity.
We'll just close a few
windows and put focus
on our GitHub gist.
This gist contains
all the code that we
are writing during
this tutorial so you
don't have to watch me type.
You can access this gist
at the URL on the screen.
Let's just briefly
look at the files
before we copy them
into our project.
First we have an
application.java,
which we'll use as a way
to store messages retrieved
from our back end API.
You will want to use
content provider instead
of a global variable like this.
But we're doing this for
sample code simplicity.
The next file is the
main activity file.
All the code pertaining to
connecting to the back end API
is commented out.
The code that is
not commented out
implements a simple
list adapter that
will let us display messages
on the screen retrieved
from the back end API.
The next XML file defines
the GUI for the app.
We'll preview this in a minute.
This file contains
a snippet of Gradle
dependencies we'll use to
compliment our client library
classes.
This final file is
a simple move script
that will move these files
into the right locations
in our sample project.
So now we'll flip over
to a new terminal window
and download this gist.
We'll also enable permissions
and execute our move script.
And now the files we
reviewed are in our project.
We'll first take a look
at the main activity
code we glossed over before.
You can see the
import statements
for the client library
are throwing an error.
That's because we need to
generate our client library.
Let's do that now.
To do this, we'll flip back
to our terminal window.
We'll stop our back
end API server.
And we'll run this
endpoints_get_client_lib goal
via Maven.
This will generate
the client library.
Next we'll move the zip file
continuing the generated Java
classes to our
current directory.
Then we'll unzip it and move it
to our Android product source
directory.
Then we'll restart our
local back end API server.
We'll now switch back
to Android Studio
and reference this Gradle
build file dependency snippet.
We're going to copy this and
paste it into the build Gradle
file for our project.
This will put all
the dependencies
that the generated
client library
code needs into our project
so that we can build and run.
We'll now save and force
a rebuild of the project.
If you still have some
unresolved imports,
you likely need to run the sync
project with Gradle function
here.
Next, we're going to look
at the GUI layout that we
that we received from our gist.
It's a simple layout
with a simple button
for our back end for
each of the API methods.
First, we can get
a message by ID.
You'll notice we use the onclick
attribute to dynamically invoke
methods in our code.
Next, we have a button
to list all the greetings
on the server.
Here we have a send
greeting button,
which maps to the multiply
message on the back end.
Finally, in this UI,
you'll notice a list view
at the bottom, which we'll
use to display our messages.
You probably also
noticed the Sign
In button and the
Authenticated Message buttons.
We won't talk about
those in this video.
But full details
are in the read me
as a full sample
code I referenced
at the beginning of the video.
We'll now close this and go
back to our main activity code.
The first code we're
going to comment in
is the onclick list
greeting method.
This method is invoked
when the List Greetings
button is clicked on the
GUI we just looked at.
You'll see we're using an
anonymously defined AsyncTask
to make our back end API calls.
On that background
thread, we are first
getting a handle to our back
end API via this utility method.
We'll then create a list
greeting command object.
And we immediately invoke
it to retrieve a greeting.
We pass the retrieve greeting
back from the method.
And then it's passed back to
us in the onPostExecute method
right here.
In this method, we'll
use the Display Greetings
utility to display it in our UI.
This line of code then
kicks off this anonymously
defined AsyncTask
without any parameters.
We'll next uncomment
onclick get greeting
to implement get greeting
button functionality.
This looks the same as
before, except we're
getting the greeting ID
parameter from the UI here.
We format it for
use in our API call.
And then we use the
AsyncTask here again.
Finally, we'll
comment in the onclick
send greetings method to
implement the last button.
The only real difference
here is that we're
pulling two parameters from the
UI instead of one, as before.
Now, we'll take a look
at some of the utility
code we used above.
This first method
is the one we used
to get a handle to
our back end API.
We're constructing
a builder object
that was supplied by the
generated API classes.
We are using two class variables
here to construct our builder.
Let's comment those in above.
As you can see, we're commenting
in Android compatible JSON
factory and an HTTP transport.
Let's scroll back down.
In this builder, we
have the capability
of providing a
different root URI.
This is a handy way of
redirecting your client library
to point to your local
development or testing servers.
We're going to do that right
now with my IP address.
This is so any API
calls we make will
go against my local
development server
from the Android emulator.
The final code we'll
comment in here
is the Display Greetings method.
This method simply
updates our list adapter
to display the
greetings passed to it.
Again, you typically want
to use content providers
to store and provide
data to list adapters.
But we are simplifying
this sample code.
The code down here
is the list adapter
we saw earlier in the
GitHub gist, nothing new.
We're close to being
finished, I promise.
Next, we'll add
internet permissions
to our Android manifest file.
We'll adjust our UI style to be
dark instead of the light one.
This will make our
content a little bit more
visible when we run
it in the emulator.
We're about done.
Let's go ahead and
start an emulator.
We click here and
create an emulator.
Any will do unless you've added
authentication to your API.
And in that case, you would
need to select a Google APIs
emulator.
We'll start this emulator.
And I'll scale it so that
it fits on the screen.
Remember to utilize the
accelerator extension
in the SDK manager if it is
available for your development
platform.
OK, now that we're up and
running with the emulator,
let's make one last change.
We need to define our
custom application
class in our Android manifest.
I'll do that really quick here.
And then we'll deploy
to our emulator.
Whoo.
It's running.
Alright.
The first thing we'll
test is list greeting.
We click the button.
And we can see hello and
goodbye world messages.
These are the same
messages we saw
when we used the
API explorer before.
Now, we'll test get greeting
by putting in an index of zero.
And it returns the
correct hello world
greeting from the back end API.
The ID of 1 returns the goodbye
greeting correctly as well.
Then we'll test send greetings
by putting in a text message
and specify that it needs
to be repeated three times.
And the back end
API successfully
returned our message
here as well.
Well, that's about it.
Our tests are working.
And our new Android
application is communicating
with an API we're running
on our local server.
I want to thank you
all for your time.
The Google Cloud Platform
Team looks forward
to seeing what you
build with this.
And we look forward to
your feedback as well.
Thanks.
[WHOOSH]